chris is in baltimore hey chris welcome
to the dave ramsey show
hi dave um this is amazing for me i
actually grew up listening to your show
my parents
turned their life around with your
advice so i'm really appreciative well
i'm honored how can we help today sir
um so i'm 22 i graduate college
on sunday yay what's your degree in
that's in economics congratulations
thank you i am lucky enough to have
no debt from school and um i have a job
locked down i also have three months
expenses saved
um and my fiance is in school to be a
physician's assistant currently
and because of her program she'll incur
some significant debt
so i'm trying to weigh um saving for
retirement once i start my job versus
saving to be ready to hit that debt hard
once we get married
chris when do you guys get married um
it's not going to be until she graduates
so it's over a year away
okay well for you i mean i would i would
definitely be focusing on your
retirement right now
because praying everything i'm sure you
sound
very responsible very in love so i'm
sure this wedding is going to happen
but what i would do is still take
advantage
of the 401k at the company if you have
that or roth ira
and then on the side if you want to save
some money
just in general and what you can earmark
that for for a year from now when you
guys get married that you can throw at
her debts for sure because it'll be your
debt together
at that point or you could even use it
as a down payment on a home
later in life too whatever you want to
do but just earmarking it
on the side but not
i would still fund retirement how much
student loan does she have
that is she going to have um it's
likely going to be at or around a
hundred thousand dollars
ooh that might change the answer
okay and you you make what
i'll be making 65 000 a year okay and
then she'll be making probably about
that when she comes out roughly too so
you have 130 000
income with a hundred thousand dollars
in student loan debt yeah
with it being that much i might uh delay
retirement for one year
you would pause it really yeah and just
let's pile up cash and get ready for the
marriage
because as soon as you walk down the
aisle you're a hundred thousand dollars
in debt
and you got to get that cleaned up then
before you start retirement and you're
22 you've got plenty of time to get to
retirement
either answer is going to be okay
there's not
neither one of us are you know neither
one of our answers are wrong
it's just a matter of i i think you're
it sure
it sure would be cool if uh out of 65
000 in 18 months you had put aside 60
and you only had to knock out 40 when
you got married
well you'd write a check after you
walked down the aisle for 60 because you
had a pile of money laying there
and and then you'd have to knock out 40
when you got married and she passes her
her uh her bars and uh you know her her
licensing and all that and is able to go
forward but yeah i
i because you're going to have to stop
retirement after
if you're only going to do it you're
only going to do it for one year that's
fair
and then you're going to stop it and get
because you're going to be back in debt
but either way it's okay i mean you
could do your roth ira for one year like
rachel's saying
it's not a not a not a wrong answer here
uh
the fact that you're 22 you're
graduating in economics she's graduating
as a pa
and you're even asking these questions
makes you a genius
i mean you're just so far ahead of the
rest of your classmates
because they're going to wander around
some of them for a decade before they
can find a checkbook
and so you're just way ahead dude you
know so
neither one of these things is going to
mess you up good good call thank you man
and congratulations